[Music]
three-time Grammy nominee Luis FONSI is
bringing his breakout hit to Madison
Square Garden it's gonna be a historic
performance I'm so happy to be able to
join that a Yankee you know we have the
model that's in the video who's our Miss
Universe alayka is gonna be it's gonna
come out and do her thing so it's really
like the family back together and I hope
that everybody at home just gets up out
of their chair out of their couch and
just dances with us because that's
that's what it's all about it's a big
Latino party baby to be able to perform
with everybody involved New York City
Madison Square Garden you know a song
that broke the language barrier a song
that broke every record first you know
for a Latin for Latin music and to be
able to celebrate that in the biggest
music award show in the world it is
already historic you know especially you
know as a Latino so III think that's the
special thing to be able to speak my
language and and to tell everybody hey
we're here let's dance a little bit
let's have a good time
[Music]
et caught up with Fonzie at rehearsals
for the 60th annual Grammy Awards airing
Sunday on CBS he's setting the record
straight on whether Justin Bieber will
join in on the performance obviously I
would love to perform it with him you
know we I've only performed it with him
once and was actually like impromptu you
know our performance at his concert so
um yeah unfortunately he's not gonna be
here but we hope that we can make him
proud man we hope that he enjoys that
wherever he is of course we extended the
invitation he's part of the nomination
you know and he helped the song grow
even more you know and and and I'm so
proud of the job that he did I'm so
proud that he decided to sing you know
most of the song in Spanish the chorus
in Spanish so we're very grateful he's a
good friend he's a good guy so I'm you
know hopefully we'll be able to to
celebrate together the record-breaking
song is up for record of the year song
of the year and pop duo or group
performance being from Puerto Rico
growing up here in the United States you
know I've always been so proud of my
roots in my language and and you know
all these artists were performing
they've all influenced me so to be able
to celebrate a little bit of Who I am
and where I'm from and to share with the
world
to break that language barrier
especially after everything that we've
been going through you know Puerto Rico
has been going through some tough couple
of months after the hurricane so um you
know just to bring a little happiness a
little light literally a little like you
know in in in their life whether we win
or not I think this is already just good
vibes for everybody
[Music]
you